hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 3 video
I feel like this season has done a good
job of like one-upping itself every
single episode and even though Fight
Club here was really badass I still feel
like Fitz and Simmons was the best
storyline it's so weird and awesome to
see like what a 180 those two characters
are done since last season like Hunter
was always a fun character like it was
it was such a win when they brought him
on the show
so really the surprise of the season 3
has been Fitz and Simmons but just
careful for spoilers as we get into it
so I'm gonna do top 5 WTF moments and
I'll try to explain where some of this
is going some of the twists were very
obviously telegraphed like we knew all
about the hunter Hydra stuff that was
gonna happen that wasn't a surprise at
all the Simmons stuff was the surprise
starting with number 5 though Coulson
and Rosalind are going to be working
together and they're kind of like twins
she even has her own male gendered
version of Lola eyes up here buddy every
missing hand joke that you could
possibly imagine
you do get the vibe that they're kind of
like this old married couple like they
have this instant rapport with each
other they just this witty banter where
it's like they don't hate each other but
they pretend that they do if they ever
got too buddy-buddy I feel like it would
ruin things like just the way things are
right now it's just just perfect just
more of this then working together like
that phone call at the end is just the
sign that you're gonna get a lot more
scenes with them like you're gonna see
more moments like this happen more
frequently yes Daisy's pissed about it
but this is actually not a bad thing if
Roslyn were gonna be evil they would
present her as evil they just want you
to think that she's gonna be an
antagonist
obviously she and Cole are gonna fight
it out for most of the season then
they'll work together because a bigger
threat will come along has it right now
the big candidates for that are Ward
with Hydra like he's slowly rebuilding
Hydra then there's lash and then there's
whatever is going on on Simmons planet
those three things all much bigger
threats than roselyn's organization on
the number four though Lincoln on the
run so very clearly they were gonna
bring him in eventually I'm kind of glad
they didn't draw this out too long
because you think by now he would
already come to his senses and tried to
work with team Coulson or have been
captured by Roslin's group they did an
amazing job of presenting his
relationship with this sober companion
it sounds like he was actually an
alcoholic in the past with suicidal
tendencies so very clearly there's
trauma and Lincoln's past that we
haven't seen yet the trauma was like a
big theme in this episode
TSD people trying to survive trauma
simmons is just like the very obvious
face of that but you have like Colson
who's trying to get over his missing
hand you have Daisy that's trying to get
over losing her mother lots of people
with PTSD all over the show so when
Lincoln accidentally killed his friend
you actually actually felt it they did a
really good job of establishing their
rapport this isn't the first time he
called me so like definitely high-fives
to the writers for that anytime you can
make a really brief appearance by
character really compelling it's always
a giant win but on the number three
drinks at the British pub so main hunter
very clearly trying to infiltrate what
they find out is Hydra I don't know that
they know that it's Hydra but I think
they have an idea the whole the whole
idea is is that may and Hunter are going
after Ward they need to infiltrate Hydra
to do that this guy here is they're in
they need to fight their way and if you
ever watched the first Ninja Turtles
movie where they you go like down the
levels of the foot clans training center
like you have to wing your way into the
foot so the minute they establish that
Hunter was gonna have to fight his way
and all I could think about was that old
Ninja Turtles movie if it had actually
been Ninja Turtles though then may would
like to flick the lights out and beat
everyone up then flicked them back on to
make it look like hunter did it but he
goes full-on rage face pulls out the
brass knuckles and the funny thing is is
that even though his name is hunter on
the TV show the actor's name is Nick
blood and he winds up covered in blood
on the show so thus far this is my new
favorite reaction face on agents of
shield season 3 when he gets taken I
feel like most people kind of knew that
this person was Ward second-in-command
so it's like ok so when they panned over
and you see the hide reveal like it you
still feel like it's still a big moment
but you kind of saw it coming in the
distance on to number two this tries to
help Simmons react ylim 8 to life on
earth the whole Simmons setup was great
just like the way that she's reacting to
all these earth-based sounds it sounds
like what happened is is she just
learned to associate certain sounds with
the people that were hunting her or the
things they said there was flora but not
fauna that means there were plants on
the alien world but she didn't see any
animals so I assume when they said there
weren't any animals they were they
weren't talking about whatever was
hunting her but essentially she's just
exhibiting classic PTSD like you know
you come back from a war and you just
you you can't handle all the sights and
sensations from everything just
because you're so used to the alien
environment of where you've been but
actually if you've seen the Martian this
past weekend Ridley Scott movie they get
really sciency about what it's like to
live in a foreign environment they
actually kind of do that in this episode
so I really appreciated it but there are
actually some really serious
consequences to your body being in an
alien environment for an extended period
spoiler alert if you go into space you
will be super cool but it will destroy
your body so if anything Simmons should
be more strung out but I mean this is TV
so they don't want they don't want to
linger too much on the moment she's
still gonna be experiencing like these
crazy side effects but now she has a
purpose which kind of dovetails nicely
to my number one WTF moment
Simmons is trying to get back to the
alien planet the shocking twist isn't so
much that she's trying to get back it's
that everything that we've seen from her
character makes it seem like that was a
terrible place that you would never want
to go back to she already told Fitz that
her curiosity died when the fear set in
so what is it that she's trying to get
back to very clearly it's something
creer elated because it's a Kree Monell
if they took her there but I'm just
guessing that it's more complicated than
some sort of like weird human hunting
future sport planet is probably another
curie outpost with other Inhumans living
there we haven't seen a whole lot of
evidence yet but I am expecting that to
loop back around on the lash plot like
they'll tie lash to this other place
this other planet in the comments though
last showed up on earth so that they
might just keep him there but I'd be
totally cool if they changed things in
the comics and they tied him to this
alien planet because clearly he has to
have a reason for wanting to kill all
these other new Inhumans we don't know
that they're doing the exact comic book
storyline in the comics they just he
went around killing new Inhumans because
he thought they were unworthy of taking
in the Terrigen mists so let me know in
the comments what do you think it is
that Simmons is trying to get back to
that planet for what is it that's so
important on that terrible looking
planet that she has to get back to
really this episode was Easter Egg light
there weren't too many references to
comic book storylines I mean we really
we haven't really seen lash in a while
either he's the closest thing to a comic
book store line that we have secret
warriors is a comic book storyline to
Coulson just explained that I was gonna
try and put a team together but that
didn't happen eventually it will
definitely happen we will see a secret
Warriors team do you'll know the really
funny thing about this episode is isn't
comic book related it was just when they
were doing
video game integration like anytime
characters play a video game and it
lingers on the screen it's probably
because the video game people paid for
them to put it in the TV show I'm
totally cool with it
they did a Jaguar ad the other week
whenever work was driving that Jaguar
around but because I'm moving into a new
apartment next week suddenly in this
scene that couch became the most
interesting character I just think it's
funny how sometimes like objects or
locations can be characters in and of
themselves so the really big news is
tonight we're gonna meet anarchy on
arrow season 4 so be sure to check the
episode out I'll post my video after it
airs I'm doing a reverse flash ring
giveaway so be sure to subscribe to get
everything
if there's any other Marvel videos you
guys want me to do this week just let me
know I've already done a daredevil
trailer video Punisher Elektra gonna be
freaking awesome I am talking to Netflix
about doing some special Jessica Jones
related stuff but that might not happen
for a couple weeks you know I'll keep
you guys posted if something really cool
ends up happening so why you guys wait
for arrow to post tonight you can click
here for my daredevil season 2 trailer
and you can click here for my flash
episode 2 video from last night thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys a little bit
you